the u.s supreme court is considering
arguments about president trump's policy
to exclude illegal immigrants
from the census it's a huge issue
because the census determines
congressional representation
and funding decisions in each state
correspondent david spunt has an update
tonight
there are approximately 11 million
undocumented immigrants in the united
states
and the trump administration wants to
remove all of them from the 2020 census
in one of his last acts in office the
president hopes to take the modified
final count
and pass it on to congress the real
fight here is substantive over how much
discretion the president has
but removing millions of people means
removing millions of dollars from states
and cities
texas california and new jersey are just
some of the states expected to lose
funding
and potentially congressional
representation if the trump team wins in
court
justices from both wings of the court
appeared skeptical of the
administration's ask
especially under a tight deadline there
are only
31 days left in the year to exclude the
10.5 million
seems to me a monumental task we have to
decide as a matter of law
whether the word persons as used in the
statute and constitution
who live here permits the exclusion of
illegal aliens
this case marks the first big test for
justice amy coney barrett
as it relates to executive power and how
much power
the man who appointed her to the bench
can harness this is the first
time in history a president has
unilaterally moved
to remove millions of undocumented
immigrants from the census
and justice barrett questioned the
administration's move
a lot of the historical evidence and the
long-standing practice really cuts
against your position
the president is supposed to receive the
final census numbers by december 31st
but that date could slide because of the
pandemic if it slides past january 20th
president biden could withdraw the case
from the supreme court
and keep the 11 million in the final
census count
brett david thank you